[Music]
hi
i'm rio and i'm the owner of kim's
champion repair today i'm doing a
installation
on a pair of chanel ballerina flats that
retail for around 750 dollars
the heel plates have one out so now i'm
taking off the older heel plates
with an opener for the replacement
[Music]
now i'm sanding the leather bottom
source of the shoes to make them
even and also open up the surface to
enhance
adhesion as i attach the leather soles
with
new rubber soles later
the bottom of the shoes have become worn
out
so they need protection soles i'm
preparing new rubber stores
and lower heel plates i'm drawing a line
in pencil to mark
where the new slow goes
the front sores have become detached
so now i'm applying a leather glue to
reattach them
[Music]
i'm using a glue brush to apply leather
glue
to the bottom of the shoes where the new
rubber soles goes
i'm reading shoes for around 20 minutes
to dry
the glue on the bottom of the shoes
before i'm adding a second coat
[Music]
bottom swords are dried now so i'm using
a heat gun to warm up the
both leather saws and lower soles to all
the hair better
[Music]
i'm using a hammer to press new source
onto the shoes
[Music]
now i'm cutting the edge of rubber soles
and heel plates with
knife
[Music]
and using a grinder motion to trim the
edge of
[Music]
shoes
[Music]
i'm using a horsehair brush and suede
brush to remove dust from the shoes
[Music]
and i'm using a suede cleaner to clean
the suede area with a suede cleaning
brush
[Music]
especially i have to be more careful
with reviving
faded suede because the color was
illegally faded and some part of suede
nap
was missed
[Music]
i'm brushing the shoes after cleaning
them to reflect the suede pile
[Music]
now i'm using a masking tape to cover
non-suede area to
avoid any damage from dying's weight
i'm using a paintbrush to apply suede
dye
to suede area and doing this a couple of
[Music]
times
the leather on the shoes have become
scuffed and faded
so i'm going to re-dye them
i'm using a black leather dye with a
paint brush to re-dye the leather
i'm using a leather paint to retouch up
the edge of the shoes
[Music]
i'm applying a finisher to leather tool
box and leather sole edges to protect
paints from minor scratches or scraps
[Music]
now i'm applying a waterproofing spray
to protect
shoes from water damage mink oil is a
product made from the very layer
under mink skins
it took a couple of days to complete the
repair
[Music]
you